maybe I strap your thug on this one and
your was good YouTube was crappy baby
you don't say oh what's going on YouTube
now there are things in this wasn't
annoying me and I know I know YouTube
because we all have Pepe's one lady
subscriber asked David what are some of
the annoying things that we girls do
that we don't know about oh do you
really want me to answer this now don't
say I don't love my subscribers because
if you thought it was hot for me to get
a woman befo about to kill that
possibility we already know what it is
stop saying you only date a specific
type of guy for example
Asian girls let's say this are the most
annoying thing on earth oh my god is
what you only date white boys [ __ ] what
you got a Ku Klux coochie and I don't
know what you think the two Asian girls
aren't the only one sis's be doing it to
citizens I'm tell you something want you
to somebody else go ahead and pick your
Black Panther God I am I said two things
wrong with this know what if you're not
that don't say that you're fat cuz you
just offended all the bigger girls
around you WTF oMG lol aren't i fat no
[ __ ] you're skinny double kill
yourself if you are fed don't ask if
you're fat you'd already know this
lookie here Jabba the gut you know that
you are chunky so don't ask us to lie to
you you knew that when you walk on the
scale this morning and he said ever it
said that for a reason if you do not
like the way you look and do something
about it change it I'm pretty sure that
your man thinks you're beautiful at the
end of the day ladies your man can tell
you that you are beautiful every day but
if you don't feel it it doesn't mean
anything doesn't stop fishing for
compliments
guess what I'm a sexy [ __ ] I hate it
when women fish for compliments cuz we
already know what your pitiful ass is
trying to do oh my hair is so ugly isn't
it no baby you're beautiful you're a
unicorn or some [ __ ] you should not have
to ask me for me to tell you that you
are beautiful see I noticed these things
when I tell you that you're beautiful I
mean it I repeat you should never have
to look to others to validate your worth
in your beauty
now I understand that your men everyday
should probably do something to tell you
that you're beautiful but at times men
are stupid
wisten we're stupid be confident
yourself if you mama
feel good about yourself you should wake
up every morning and look at the mirror
and say excuse me you got a little
something on your face mr. sexy duck
face you know what I'm talking about
Jesse cakes there are few of you who do
not know what the duck face is the duck
face is a common facial expression that
women make when they take the picture
smile that's pop all the Uglies [ __ ]
face I've ever seen one it looks like
you try to spell you upper lip oh my god
with this nut - it looks like the guilty
face of someone who just [ __ ] himself
Oh three women activists hypocrites here
that's why I know what the [ __ ] I'm
talking about you know the women are
talking about the old verbally gung-ho
about women's rights but in reality you
know they you know base of house do you
realize that you are doing a huge
disservice to women all across the earth
let me tell you something actions always
speak louder than words and if you want
to be respected as a woman you better do
a better job of hiding your coochie
coochie for example how are you gonna
talk about you hate the way women are
depicted in media when all of a sudden
this song comes on to the WoW do the
sweat drip down my bow then you're like
oh [ __ ] that's my jam
were you serious are there more things
that women do that men hate hell yes
and ladies don't become believe you're
hanging you because there are plenty of
[ __ ] that men do their women hate and
I'm gonna dress this up next week so
ladies out there if you still looking
for a man who's really outspoken and
does his damn thing right here baby
right here a little climbing you
you
[Music]